if you are hitting the road this labor  day you'll need to shell out a little  more cash for gas prices are up  nationwide and the highest levels are  here on the west coast in california  prices at the pump are averaging 443 a  gallon according to aaa the current  national average is 3 18 a gallon that's  almost a dollar more than this time last  year it comes as an estimated 43 million  americans hit the road over the next few  days  when gas prices are high heading into a  holiday weekend that does not deter most  people from traveling because so many  people make their plans way in advance  before they know what the pump prices  are going to be heading into a holiday  weekend  the average price per gallon in nevada  is just above four dollars the same goes  for clark county it's dropped about  three cents in the last week overall  prices are expected to drop after this  weekend